le torchon brûle entre l'union
européenne et le royaume uni dans un
contexte de négociations commerciales
difficiles
boris johnson a une nouvelle fois
déclenché la colère de bruxelles le
premier ministre britannique veut faire
adopter un projet de loi qui contredit
en partie l'accord encadrant sa sortie
de l'europe
malgré la réunion de crise convoquée par
la commission européenne ce jeudi le
parti conservateur souhaite maintenir ce
projet de loi une violation des accords
contestés par les ministres européens
nous avons beaucoup travaillé pour
rendre le break site réalisable mais il
est nécessaire d'obtenir les accords qui
ont été prévus il est clair que chacun
doit s'en tenir à ce qui a déjà été
accepté les traités doivent être
respectés et c'est ce que tout le monde
dont le même temps
londres tourne de plus en plus le dos à
ses partenaires européens
boris johnson espère parvenir à un
accord commercial avec les états unis
avant la fin de l'année et ce vendredi
le gouvernement britannique vient de
conclure un traité de libre-échange avec
le japon
une ouverture vers de nouveaux alliés
dont se félicite boris johnson
le royaume uni vient de signer un
important accord de libre-échange avec
le japon
félicitations à l'iss trust et à tous
ceux qui ont participé à ces
négociations
nous avons repris le contrôle de notre
politique commerciale et continueront de
prospérer en tant que nation commerçante
en dehors de l'union européenne
déterminé à aller vite le gouvernement
de boris johnson entend présenter dès ce
lundi son projet de loi au parlement
de quoi compliquer un peu plus les
pourparlers avec l'union européenne qui
devrait reprendre la semaine prochaine